lady in the room hi hi Malaysia I'm the
producer of this two routes and I will
show you our game in a bit
awesome tell me about speed
Hanneman
you
Oh
yeah
Oh
Oh
robot invasion yeah
why are they doing this to us
so we have a vision for their level into
arrest
how does it work
and
so we got to the world
yes
yeah
very dark but at the same time and then
having that type of narrative behind I
require
having robots who hate us it's really
cool to some glass
yeah
[Music]
the fight isn't about the horizont
acting in an Internet age
yeah
[Music]
objectives in the third quarter inning
in the corner so we got to proceed to
the mercury posit as to next objective
it seems
right
thank you
proceed
now is that it is more behind the fights
himself anything any story behind the
that's almost like like the sons of
anarchy
what
completely understand still rats this is
really cool game looks great
what my phone is my boss here this the
rats are trying to release okay
maybe some on attendance
I guess the one asset because there's a
another motorcycle game will take that
carbon styles yeah no I try to get any
fix it didn't bite dog this game is
great and hopefully looks great thank
you so much bill Badshah